Skilled craftsmen and tradespeople and factory workers have seen the jobs they loved...
...shipped thousands and thousands of miles away.
Many Pennsylvania towns once thriving and humming are now in a state of total disrepair.
This wave of globalization has wiped out totally our middle class.
It doesn't have to be this way.
We can turn it around, and we can turn it around fast.
But if we're going to deliver real change,...
...we're going to have to reject the campaign of fear and intimidation,...
...being pursued by powerful corporations, media elites, and political dynasties.
The people who rigged the system for their benefit will do anything and say anything...
...to keep things exactly the way they are.